all right this is a different sort of
story I don't want to go all like public
service announcement on people but I am
so desperate to try to figure out how we
can solve this issue that I feel
obligated to say something about it and
that's that the texting while driving
just has to stop it is such a dangerous
behavior that is spreading like a virus
I mean it's everywhere and to be clear I
was 20 some years ago I took more risks
when driving than I do today I would go
a little too fast than I do a little
faster than it then I go today when it's
icy out I would look at text messages
here and there while driving but then
respond when I was stopped at a traffic
light but the degree to which this
behavior is leading to accidents and
deaths and destruction has become
outrageous I I'm finding myself almost
at a loss for words because it is
everywhere I saw it in London last week
someone looking down and texting while
driving and just rolling at ten miles an
hour right through a red light into an
intersection and almost causing a crash
on the highway here in Massachusetts I
90 called the MassPike inside of
Massachusetts you can spot the textures
from a mile away I start coming up on
someone in the fast lane the leftmost
lane and they're going 60 when the speed
limit is 65 and usually in the fast lane
you're going 70 or 75 to get around
people I go over to the middle lane
arguably dangerous in and of itself
since you're not really supposed to pass
on the right but necessary to get away
from these people and I look over and
the person has no idea that they are
creating a backup in the fast lane
looking down at their phone and texting
from a quarter-mile back you see
someone's sort of meandering left and
right not staying in their lane it looks
like it could be a drunk driver but it's
noon
nope not drunk it's just someone on
their phone looking up only every other
second and when you're going 40 or 50 or
60 you're covering a lot of ground in
that second when you're not looking at
the road here in Boston there are lots
of sort of complicated four and five Way
intersections the city's known for them
some are always stopped some are two-way
stop some are to one ways that meet and
both have to turn on to another one-way
and every week someone on their phone
misunderstands the intersection and
almost causes an accident that I see and
I'm sure that lots of them become real
accidents that I don't see the number of
near misses that I've had with people
who are merely on their phones is
certainly in the dozens and the thing
about it is so many people who do it
think that their driving is not impaired
distracted driving is shown to be like
drunk driving and in a sense it could
even be worse because people who are
slightly buzzed will often because they
know that they will pay extra attention
when they're driving believe me I am NOT
saying it's okay to drive when buzzed
it's not but people who do this with
their phones they often don't say oh I'm
doing something that is dangerous so I
should pay extra attention in fact
they're doing it the phone stuff because
they believe that it does not impair
them in any way and I've actually had
conversations with people who say you
know the thing about texting while
driving is some people can do it and
some people can't some people are good
at it and some are not I happen to be
one of the people that can do it I'm not
like those people who drive bizarrely
when they are texting and I'm sure that
it's a bell-curve to some degree
different people are affected to
different degrees when they're texting
while driving but with so many people
doing it wouldn't you want to have all
of your attention on the road to make
sure that some other distracted driver
doesn't run a red light or stop sign and
hit you this is an area where not only
strict but likely to be enforced
penalties seem to make a difference but
that's the key thing they have to be
likely to be enforced because one of the
things that we know is that it's not
just the severity of the punishment that
deters actions we know that it doesn't
in many cases when you look at for
example the death
penalty versus life in prison without
parole it doesn't appear that the
possibility of the death penalty is a
deterrent to people committing murder
but when you look at something like this
or when you look at you know jaywalking
is often an example it's a combination
of not just the severity of the
punishment but how likely you are to get
caught I have friends in Sweden who tell
me you know I don't understand what's
going on in the US the punishments here
are not only severe for drunk driving
but they are likely to be enforced we
feel like we are likely to be caught so
if we're having one beer maybe two but
in many cases even one beer we don't
drive we get an uber or you get a
designated driver or whatever you just
don't chance it because it is taken that
seriously I don't know what the solution
is here especially with overloaded
police departments often by the way
overloaded focusing on the wrong things
like jailing people for marijuana but
something has to be done I don't know
what it is and there it seems to be
beyond reason I don't know if it's
related to decrease the tension spans
we're simply driving alone is not enough
stimulus for the brain where people feel
like they need to take out their phones
and start scrolling or texting people
are looking at Instagram I don't know
what it is but it's spreading like a
virus and I am open to hearing ideas
from people in the audience as to what
it is that should be done